Now Sarah has just shown you how one can use object tracing to find a bug in a
method implementation. And I'd like to show you another kind of bug that's
fairly common. So over here I have my drive method. I drive a given distance, I
update the miles driven. I compute the gas consumed. I update the gasInTank.
And when I compile it, I get an error message. Where it says can not find
symbol variable gas consumed. It's complaining over here. Now it's a common
error to now say oh, it can't find it so let me just make another instance
variable. So on the surface it doesn't seem like an error because the class
will compile and actually the code will kind of work but it's really inelegant.
Let's use the tracing technique to find out why. Note that this class now has
four instance variables. Here they are on an index card. And now let's quickly
run through the same scenario that we had previously. The car gets constructed,
we add 30 gallons, we drive 10 miles. That consumes a gallon. We then drive 20
miles for a total of 30, that consumes 2 gallons. We're left with 27 gallons.
So what's wrong? Have a look at this variable. The stuff that it remembers is
short-term information. The amount of gas consumed the last time we drove,
that's just like remembering what pizza you had for lunch. You don't really
need to remember this long term. There's absolutely no need to remember these
values after a call to drive, they should be short term memory that should be a
local variable. Okay, let's make it so. Over here let's not make gas consumed
into an instance variable. Over here we turn it into a local variable simply by
adding the type. Remember the difference between an assignment and a variable
declaration is nothing but the type. Now the code will compile. And when we
review the instance variables up here, we'll find there are no unnecessary one.
Your car does need to remember the miles driven at a gas level across multiple
method calls. And of course, it needs to know the mileage so that it can
compute the gas consumption. So you've just seen how the technique of object
tracing gives us an insight into what an object does and it let's us find some
errors.